تحرير المحتجزين الاسرائيليين لدى حماس
هدف الحرب المعلن ولتحقيق احالت اسرائيل
معظم القطاع الى ركام قتلت اكثر من 23 الف
فلسطيني خلال 100 يوم وبالنسبه لاهالي
المختطفين هذا الكلام اين يصرف الى متى
سننتظر نريد عوده ابنائنا سالمين وباي ثمن
فنظموا بمناسبه مرور 100 يوم على اسر ذويه
مهرجان شارك فيه نحو 12 الف شخص هو الاكبر
في تل ابيب منذ بدء الحرب في ساحه الرهائن
المقابله لوزاره الدفاع للضغط على الحكومه
لجعل ملف المحتجزين اولويه استمرت هذه
الاحتجاز ليوم كامل منذ مساء السبت هل
اصبحت مساله الاسرى ملفا للصراع السياسي
الداخلي فعضو مجلس الحرب ورئيس حزب معسكر
الدوله بيني جانس انضم لتظاهرات اهالي
الاسرى الذين استمروا بال وقوف منذ مساء
السبت عضو مجلس الحرب جادي ايزنكوت قال
علينا ان نتوقف عن الكذب على انفسنا وان
نظهر الشجاعه وان نتجه الى صفقه كبيره
تعيد المختطفين الوقت ينفد وكل يوم يمر
على المختطفين في غزه يعرض حياتهم للخطر
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي استهل جلسه
الحكومه بالموافقه على الموازنه بالحديث
عن الاسرى هذا ما
قاله
لقد اعدنا نصف الرهائن ولن نتخلى عن احد
نبذل قصار جهدنا عادتهم جميعا الى ديارهم
واؤكد جميعهم بلا استثناء وهذه الجهود
مستمره في كل الاوقات حتى في هذه اللحظه
وسنستكمل عمليه اعادتهم في الوقت نفسه
الذي نستكمل فيه الاهداف الاخرى للحرب
بالقرب من تظاهره اهالي الاشر في تل ابيب
تظاهر محتجون مناهضون لحكومه نتنياهو
وطالب باقالته واجراء انتخابات جديده
اغلقوا طريقا سريعا بينما اتجه اخرون نحو
مقر اقامه رئيس الوزراء فحاولت الشرطه فض
تظاهره واشتبكت مع المحتجين واعتقلت البعض
منهم انتم كيف علقتم على هذه التظاهرات
وهي الاكبر في تل ابيب لاهالي الاشرا بعد
مرور 100 يوم على حرب غزه احمد مطر يقول
احمد نتنياهو وحكومته المتطرفه والكنيست
لا يعنيهم مصير الاسراء احياء ان كانوا
امواتا وما هي ظروفهم المعيشيه والصحيه
بدليل استمرار الحرب اكثر من 100 يوم
الاسرى ضحيه صراع سياسي داخليا في اسرائيل
من اجل بقاء الفاسدين والمتطرفين في
السلطه زاد قال المقاومه بتحافظ على
الاسرى في حين اسرائيل بتقتل المدنيين في
غزه ابو كليب المقاومه تعامل الاسرى
بانسانيه والخطر الوحيد عليهم هو الجيش
الصهيوني المقاومه عندها شروط واضحه
والاولى ان تضغط على حكومه اسرائيل لانهاء
الحرب وتنفيذ الشروط اما بالنسبه لعبد
الرحمن فقال بعد 100 يوم من العدوان
الاسرائيلي الامريكي على شعب فلسطين فشل
المعتدون وكان لهم
مطلبا اطلاق سراح الاسرى الاسرائيليين
والقضاء على حماس لم يحقق العدو اي مطلب
كتائب القسام نشرت ايضا تسجيلا مصورا
جديدا لثلاثه من الاسرى الاسرائيليين
لديها بعنوان حكومتكم تكذب وجه هؤلا
منا بايقاف الحرب على
غزه
[موسيقى]
8ل
ه